let's talk about brad parscale because
uh this kind of plays into that did you
have you guys seen the video of what
happened to brad yeah i watched it this
is the weirdest thing came over
so brad parscale is trump's ex-campaign
manager and the narrative from the left
is that he screwed up
trump got really mad and fired him when
he he was demoted right but they're like
he was like not unofficially fired
now they're claiming he's unwell
depressed
and we have a story where they're saying
his wife runs out of their house
screaming that her husband
she's i think my husband just killed
himself and she like jumps in a car
and this witness says the woman was
bruised and freaking out they call 9-1-1
apparently the police said that when
they arrived and looked through the
window
they're like marksmen out there they saw
him sitting on the floor with his dog
drinking a beer
and so i'm like that in the video too
he's just like
chilling with the bud light yeah right
right and then they they slam him to the
ground
this is this is actually kind of uh it
actually is kind of funny because
brad comes out and he's like just in his
shorts
no shirt drinking a beer and he's like
very slowly like
i didn't do anything like what's going
on and the cops like just come over here
buddy we're gonna talk
and then all of a sudden like five cops
start yelling get on the ground and they
run up to him and one guy grabs him by
the way and just
body slams him and then brad just puts
his hands up and he's like
what did i do i didn't do anything the
funny thing is
there were a couple people tweeting like
you know is this how we treat people
like is what cops do
and the left is laughing about it
they're like yes this is what cops do
like when someone gets called for a
mental health issue a bunch of cops show
up with guns
and they body slam them but the story is
kind of crazy because i don't know if i
believe it
you know am i supposed to get in the
middle of whatever this like domestic
dispute is between him and his wife and
just assume
that he's like this villainous bad guy
when i don't even know what happened
yeah the all the tweets about it are
basically saying he's a wife beating
you know trumper con man blah blah blah
i feel very uncomfortable even like
talking about it i tried not i didn't
even write about it for gateway i was
like this is
it just seems like a personal situation
it also seems like we don't know what
happened you know cops showed up
dude got slammed to the ground and i
don't know
but man this goes into like what i was
what i've been feeling about
social media's low information angry
people
yeah because the because the the the
left is just basically saying
that you know he's a wife beater end of
story don't care don't need evidence
sonny proof
but meanwhile jacob blake was a pristine
human being right
right right it was um what's the kid
they got up in the
native american vietnam era nicholas
sandman yeah the salmon thing is what
really
turned the corner for me when i saw that
i was infuriated him i thought he
definitely was egging that guy on and i
almost
tweeted it out i almost went social
media ham and i just for whatever reason
didn't i took a breath and i
and then like you know eight hours later
it starts to realize he's just nervous
and kind of holding his ground well i
don't understand why anyone just spun
that
so hard i don't understand why anyone
cared about that in the first place i
went into mom mode so hard
the second i saw it i was like that is a
nervous little boy how dare you
i went crazy i like i came out flying i
thought he was like a punk
like a punk kid i was like look at this
son of a
this guy not me smack he i want to beat
his face like
who does he think he is getting in that
old veteran's face like i was so mad
and then i re it was all new spin it was
like my daughter does the same thing
though like when if she gets nervous
she'll like smile and she'll just like
hang out
and so i saw him doing it and i was like
that's what rory does that's what kids
do when they're like
scared or intimidated or overwhelmed
they try and like be cool
be calm it's not even that it's like
that clip was like 20 seconds
yeah in in the slightly longer clip you
see him going like you know doing the
the kill it
hand gesture to other people like stop
it leave him alone he was actually
trying to chill everything out
i first saw that video out of context
the way everyone else saw it and i
didn't care
i'm like i i was like what what is this
they're like did you like people
people were saying to me like crazy did
you see what this kid did and i watch it
and i'm like
so yeah it's like i don't care if he did
walk up to the dude and
got in his face i don't care like
are you nuts how many you know how many
things i've seen in chicago where i'm
like
it's a million times worse i've seen
people just walk up to a random car and
start screaming
and then start like throwing rocks at it
you're like a kid walking up to a dude
to me is very low on my priorities
yeah and it turned out to be fake news
and then it jumped up on the on my list
of priorities because i'm like
why is everybody lying about this kid
this is the weirdest thing
that's it low information angry people
and that's our government now that's i
think that's mostly the democrats though
i think the republicans like lindsey
graham is panicking us i don't i don't
know
do you hear like his have you have
anything about it yeah his money
troubles
no what is it like he went on fox
apparently and was like
i need money donate to me i'm getting
killed yeah because he drinks too much
well i just don't glue it all on liquor
when rbg died he got 16
his opponent got 16 million dollars in
funds in wow one day
so he's like i have a problem i should
probably work on this
way more than his first game i'm looking
forward to all of the establishment
politicians
all the incumbents just bye-bye go away
it's conjecture rand paul
i
i talk about lindsey graham like he's an
alcoholic because he's got those
bloodshot eyes i really don't know if
he's an alcoholic but
he looks like he just has a drinking
problem yeah
i mean sorry lindsey if you don't lin
like
lindsay comes comes across to me as like
actually what's the what's the easiest
way to explain it he's like scared
of everybody so he won't do anything you
know it's like the republicans are
yelling at him like
do something and he's like oh geez like
and looks to the left
the shell of a man doesn't do anything
that's because
you think i blame the alcohol because
i've been through drinking binges and i
have like
no self-esteem afterwards i'm like
shattered
how did he keep winning anyway what were
we talking about brought him up anyway
lindsey graham begging for money i just
i just don't like
like i just don't like democrats or
republicans and
it's because trump got elected and he's
all emotional so now everyone's acting
emotional he's scared
yeah he he got elected and did it
emotionally he like yelled it
called hillary clinton stupid a bunch
made everyone laugh just a big emotion
it was a big emotional circus to get
elected and now the whole country is an
emotional overload no trump didn't make
that happen well he's a trump he's a
he's an actor
for sure but trump is a is a symptom of
the cultural change not the cause of it
go deeper on that well the like the
culture war
and gamergate type circumstances in this
rage was was building up for a long time
before trump got elected
trump got elected partly because of that
anger and because people memed him into
office
it was magical have you guys seen the
keck documentary thing i just watched it
the other night
this is the i i wish we could just sit
here and play it like eat popcorn i
actually felt bad for him
and i was like oh no what's wrong with
me sympathizing with him
uh fury whatever his name is the oh oh
the pepe guy yeah
are you talking you're talking about
like the pepe doctor no no no no no no
the the meme magic there's a video they
made back in like 2016 that explains all
these
really weird coincidences around kek
you know kak you had the little things
at the deploy ball so uh
what is it like an egyptian god yeah and
he's like a frog that's crazy
and kek is uh in world of warcraft when
you type lol
the opposing faction would see the word
kek kek
so people started saying keck as like as
lol because it was
you know was funny and then it became a
meme and then it became associated with
pepe
and jokes it became associated with the
right then it turns out that keck
or like you know whatever the god's name
was it's like a real thing
and people think that it's like like
jokingly i guess i'm sure some people
really believe it
like they memed trump into office with
like me magic it's real
you know what's funny though is they're
basically saying prayer
you know what i mean like they're saying
collective conscious
and like all of this like energy
constantly you know just pushing this
idea
results in trump getting getting elected
the bigger point is outside of any ideas
of faith or magic is that
whatever trump is and is doing is it he
he won because of
what was changed do you think gamergate
started it i think
gamergate was the first the that was the
spark of the culture
what was that 2014 i think it's like
2013. what happened exactly
oh man you're gonna have to find the old
i remember
hearing about it and just ignoring it
because i thought it was so silly
well if you ask the likes of i don't
know buzzfeed or vox or the verge
they'll say it was when a bunch of
alt-right misogynists
started harassing women because they
didn't like women playing video games
which is reductionist and ridiculous
because there's like no substance to
that argument
if you ask um you know if you ask
gamergate people it's probably they'll
probably
say something more the effect of there's
an incestuous relationship between
advertisers game developers and gaming
websites
and so what was happening is a gaming
company is putting out a game right like
you know ian's great adventure
let's say you make that game okay ian's
great adventure ian rim it's like skyrim
but you know to you
very fun and you want to sell games so
you sponsor a gaming website
they're not going to write bad things
about you because then they're going to
lose a sponsorship
so you're basically paying them to
publish a press release then they write
a story and they're like dude
ian quest is so amazing and then people
play and they're like dude this game is
terrible
and then they get mad and they're like
why was the review positive one of their
advertisers is
oh so it was like a scandal and that's
where the gate came from right i see
yeah and so depending on who you ask
you'll get different responses
the establishment media people who like
you know infected and infiltrated
mainstream
news organizations will claim it was
just a bunch of angry misogynists who
hate women
but that makes no sense because it's
like where did that come from
like what made a bunch of people angry
there was a bunch of four-year-olds
watching porn in 2004.
now they're all adults because they're
all like
they don't understand how to have sex
with a woman basically they're like 20
years old and they haven't
you're talking about the journalists
that's just why people are crazy why why
young men or
oh that's true dude for sure i was
talking to this young guy
uh several months ago who was like 26 or
something
and he was just like a virgin couldn't
get a date
yeah and uh i i i mentioned this
on like a bunch of videos before but uh
let me let me know what you think about
this
here's my basic theory when before the
age of
mobile technology and like dating apps
like tinder
young women and young men were in the
same place at like college
and so the dating pool for women was
limited to the men
in their circle the 35 year old dude
who's got his own house and got a car
and all that stuff
he's probably not going to meet this 20
year old woman for the most part
because family too no he doesn't have a
family these
a lot of guys aren't getting married but
the point i'm making is
when you get now the uh the dating apps
enter the scene now young women at
colleges
have a dating pool that has expanded
outside of college to
anywhere they're willing to drive to so
they expand their radius
from the one mile one square mile around
the school where all this you know other
men of the same age are
they expand it to you know 25 miles
all of a sudden now they're seeing older
successful guys who are like 30 35
got a car got a house and so they swipe
right on that guy
and then they swipe right on the 20 the
20 year old guy as well who's at the
university he's like oh cool he goes to
school with me
then they get two messages the guy at
the university says hey do you want to
go down to the cafeteria and grab a bite
then the 35 year old guy says hey you
want to hop in my car and drive to the
lake and then you know
go go explore and do these fun things i
got tons of cash which ones you gonna
pick
for the most part you've got a guy with
resources and you've got a guy who's in
college like her
there's probably a tendency moving
towards these these established guys who
have cash
so that what ends up happening is these
younger guys are competing
with established career men which means
they're dropping off and this this data
was actually published by the washington
post
that young men uh i think under the age
of 29
this is a couple years ago are like 30
percent more likely to be a virgin
at this time compared to the previous
generation like it's getting worse and
worse and worse
it's worth a little bit for women but
not for the most part i think it's
because
if a woman has a choice between a broke
college guy
and even somebody who's only a few years
older has got a job she'll pick the guy
out of the job
i mean that makes sense right yeah so
now what do you do when you got a bunch
of young men can't get
can't get dates i don't know they start
wishing for a traditionalist
1950s housewife where there was like
dowries and
you know marriages were arranged or
something it made it all easier you know
they didn't have to worry about it
social media changed everything made
competition much much more difficult i
wonder whether
that'll leave us off you know yeah
really thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you